where the [ __ ] did this come from seeing
the explosion of anime in the past 10
years was Bloody exciting if you were an
anime fan before suddenly this Niche
little medium you loved was starting to
get noticed by a wider audience and that
was a good thing because this must have
meant so many more great anime that
would have never been made before might
just be on the horizon the small fan run
companies we follow got an injection of
money they needed big players were
starting to get into the game there was
so much potential for cool projects so
much promise of the medium being taken
to the next level it was hectic it was
exciting the possibility seemed endless
and what did we get we've been preparing
our whole lives for this day one thing
we did get was more anime but that
didn't necessarily mean that was more
great anime the shows you wanted to
watch was split across a million
different streaming platforms and some
of the shows you were excited for had
all their possible hype killed when the
wrong platform picked it up this wasn't
on the fine print of the expectations we
had but every so often that comes along
a project that makes me remember alright
maybe anime getting worldwide
recognition wasn't such a bad thing
after all
cyberpunk Edge Runners might be one of
the most exciting collaborative projects
I've seen in years coming from Studio
trigger and CDs nuts project red this
was the type of project we were waiting
for following their very successful
launch of cyberpunk 2077 CD projekt Red
obviously saw potential for more stories
to take place in the world they had
crafted and in the process might have
accidentally made one of the best things
to come out all year continuing this
unexpected but wonderful trend of
animated video game adaptations slapping
harder than an Asian parent who'd just
been given a bad report card that's
right guys I'm a real gamer not because
I play them but because I watch them
which is the perfect time to talk about
today's sponsor honkai impact
foreign
pack third is an anime game from the
developers at hoyerverse which is a
company I've never heard of and I'm
totally not familiar with
why are you looking at me like that this
is a stunning exciting action RPG with
addictive gameplay and top tier girls
available on PC and mobile and honestly
the story is pretty damn good too no cap
right now Hong Kong impact thirds
version 6.0 just dropped with new
characters the second phase of The
Summer Event and a major update for the
main chapter there's a whole new battle
suit as Alicia the Hershey of human
joins the game with this update and come
on just look at her this is a girl you
want on your team and don't forget we
also have part two of the summer events
giving us the summer survival Rhapsody
side 13. the event includes three
chapters and just by taking part you get
a chance to win Shadow night's new
summer outfit but wait there's more
there will be two more summer outfits
that you can get for grisio and vilvy
this is why I love summer baby use the
link in the description to download the
game today and you can use the code on
screen right now to get 30 Crystal 288
asterite and Herschel trial card for
free thank you to Hong Kong impact third
for sponsoring us today and now back to
cyberpunk cyberpunk Edge Runners is a
Canon Side Story in the cyberpunk 2070 7
Universe taking place in the future in
the dark gritty violent dystopia
nightmare called the United States of
America I mean night City David is Zakir
just trying to survive in the city
attending a prestigious school being
supported by his mum despite her
struggling income
but after getting into a massive car
accident David comes David comes too to
find his mother has passed away because
she couldn't afford proper Health Care
wait a minute guys that was a joke that
was a [ __ ] joke you won't make to
take that seriously from there on he has
to resort to a life of crime meeting
Lucy a skilled cyber hacker and her
fellow gang members he joins their crew
taking on missions so they can survive
together in the underbelly of night City
alright guys I've got a confession to
make I am not actually a gamer I lied
before I don't play video games
get away shut up I haven't played
cyberpunk 2077 yet and my only prior
knowledge about it was that
the game was a little buggy so I went
into this complete complete blind and
while I'm sure I missed some Easter eggs
here and there it did not ruin my
enjoyment at all the world of night city
is stunningly brought to life under
trigger's eyes Neon Lights illuminate
the concrete jungle with a fluorescent
color palette so you can smell the
stench of stale piss wreaking from the
back alleys every random passerby feels
like they have a story to tell I think
people forgot that beyond the glitches
and T posing CD projekt Red actually
crafted a truly vibrant world with so
much potential for interesting stories
to take place Edge Runners might not
have Keanu Reeves but it does have this
guy I do not pay you to think I pay you
to check the boxes off my list wait a
minute is that my man gas from breaking
bad but you can call me sus the first
thing anyone will probably notice is
Studio triggers footprint stamped all
over the show you know as much as I like
trigger recently when I saw that name
attached to a project especially if it
was being led by this man hiroyuki
imaishi I was starting to think I was
watching a one-trick pony I remember the
first time I saw Guru in Lagan I was
blown away by the sheer absurd
over-the-top hype contained in it then I
saw killer kill and I was slightly less
Blown Away by the sheer absurd over the
top pipe contained in it then I saw Pro
map and I was puffed Away by the sheer
absurd over the top hype contains in it
and then I saw they were doing an
episode of Star Wars vision and I was
like is there going to be some sheer
absurd over-the-top hype contained in
this yep there it is now did Edge
Runners have some sheer absurd
over-the-top hype contained in it
yes but it was actually kind of muted in
comparison to all that other stuff I
mean this may look ridiculous to you but
this is just a standard Driving
Experience in India there are still
flashes of that classic balls to the
wall trigger hype but I feel like they
had to restrain themselves a bit more
than usual due to this being a Canon
story in a pre-existing universe but
because of this they needed to find more
creative ways to up the ante aside from
going into space going into space going
into space or my personal favorite going
into space and I feel like by
restricting them you got to see a whole
new side shine through off of [ __ ]
sake this in my opinion is one of their
best looking shows to date the Gunplay
on display is absolutely insane David
has a special ability to go bullet time
creating an army of after images for
every movement that he makes which
smells my mind every time I see it but
most notably this is the first time I've
seen them tackle an old school hyper
violence show and you could tell they
had so much fun Breaking All the
shackles that usually limit them bodies
get blown apart in an explosion of
bright red blood intestines go flying
out bits of skull and eyeballs rain down
with every shotgun blast seeing this
type of violence being done with the
trigger flare was a brutally beautiful
sight I didn't know I needed until now
trigger were already the masters of
giving their shows a unique visual
identity but I feel like even here
everything was polished and sharpened to
a level even further Beyond I remember
the first time I boosted up Persona 5. I
was enamored by just how much work must
have been put into his Aesthetics the
Striking color palettes the battle
animations the text messages even the
individual menus everything down to the
smallest detail seemed to be
meticulously crafted to fit this visual
style it was just so [ __ ] cool and
this is the exact same feeling I get
when watching Edge Runners every frame
is oozing with a visual flare most shows
could only dream of achieving there were
some scenes with so much going on it
felt like my brain couldn't process all
the stimuli it was receiving this wasn't
the rule of cool this was the rule of
[ __ ] cool and it was so refreshing
seeing this team's insane creativity
being pushed to a level I haven't seen
before then we got the soundtrack you
know how in most anime you got your
normal background music then during the
season finale of some [ __ ] it'll hit you
with a special insert song they've saved
up just for this moment and it's
beautiful it elevates the moment and it
kind of feels like it turns the scene
into a narrative music video yep
cyberpunk has that for like every
episode The seriously is just
overflowing with such fantastic tracks
and at some point I feel like they had
too many to work with there'd be a
throwaway scene of just two characters
talking and I'd be like
I throw to [ __ ] reggae so many scenes
felt like I was watching a stylistic
music video it was like I was watching
fuliculi all over again and then there's
the writing so you guys
cyberpunks aren't you oh they're moving
he's going for more out of everything
this is probably the least strongest
aspect but I'm only saying that because
everything else was absolutely Stellar
sure there were some awkward pieces of
dialogue here and there I'm I'm built
different bro I'm a different breed of
what I chinchilla but honestly
everything was solid and did what it
needed to do I've seen a few complaints
saying that there wasn't enough runtime
that kind of felt rushed but I didn't
get that feeling at all to me it didn't
feel rushed it just felt dense this is
10 episodes packed to the absolute brim
from start to finish the series rarely
gives you a chance to catch your breath
shit's constantly going down situations
are always evolving and while it would
have been nice to have an extra episode
or two with a bit of downtime here and
there never once did it feel like a
major story beat wasn't earned and yet
even through everything they still found
time to make a standout episode episode
6 might be one of the best episodes of
anime I've seen in years from the
opening second something feels off the
air feels heavy you find yourself being
on edge everything is draped in an air
of unease and you can't put your finger
on exactly why like you're standing in
the eye of an unseen storm and what
follows is a 20-minute psychedelic trip
down into Insanity that simply left me
speechless by the end it was an absolute
Master Class of Direction and Cinema and
it's episodes like this that remind
reminds me why the medium of Animation
is so [ __ ] incredible
even with a shorter episode count it
didn't affect how invested I was in
everything it's been a while since I've
seen I've seen an ensemble that left
such a big impression on me so quickly
everyone feels memorable without feeling
like they're just a walking Trope from
looks to personality to attitude each
character is totally distinct from one
another and have this group chemistry
that's infectious Maine walks in as the
charismatic father figure of the group
David's that eager younger brother
Rebecca was one of the more minor
characters and yet with just a few
scenes she was able to leave a stronger
impression than most characters do with
hours of screen time
my man what's going on it's serious like
this that shows you don't need hours of
backstory to get attached or like a
character everyone felt like they were a
part of this dysfunctional family and
there would be a gaping hole without
them there and you get just as emotional
when some of the major events happen
watching this reminded me of the feeling
I got when watching Cowboy Bebop I
didn't need Spike Fey or Jet's backstory
to get attached to this crew I already
was way before their respective episodes
because it was just a pleasure to spend
time with all of them you never wanted
their journey to end but you knew it had
to eventually and when it does you're
left with this Bittersweet feeling of
emptiness knowing that you've had to say
goodbye to your time with them you're
the guy who jumps into the fire to
rescue someone
anyone even when you know you're gonna
get burned cyberpunk Edge Runners is an
example of what happens when you give a
team gone mad with creativity the
resources to do what they want to do
this is what it's like watching a show
where every single person working on a
project gives a [ __ ] you can feel the
love and excitement emanating from every
single second of this run time because
absolutely no one half asked it everyone
brought their A-game not a single person
phoned it in it's as much a passion
project as it is a promotional piece for
a gaming franchise everyone had already
written off this was the project we were
promised when anime started to get more
recognition globally the prospect of
some of the most talented names in the
niche medium of anime we followed
getting to go wild with some of the
biggest names and franchises from a
totally different medium was meant to
give us more shows like this and I hope
that this isn't just the exception but
the standard for future collaborative
anime projects to come Bravo guys
[Music]
for you
[Music]
on a single t-post 0 out of 10 worst
adaptation of all time
[Music]